Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
Marvel has a brand new daredevil born again
teaser for a huge fight with Daredevil vs Bullseye
Big rematch fight scene after the end of Daredevil
Season 3 Bullseye getting his new adamantium spine.
It looks like Kieran Page is one of his new targets.
So we'll say a prayer for her.
and we have a nice shiny look at what
their new comic book suits are going to look like.
And they are way more comic book accurate.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
It's a big week for Marvel
because we have the Super Bowl.
The Deadpool three trailer
is going to be coming this weekend.
Of course I will do all the Super Bowl
trailer videos possible.
just starting with the biggest stuff.
First here, the new daredevil suit, new bullseye
suit in Daredevil versus Bullseye Rematch fight.
Finally Daredevil's new suit
looks just like the Netflix red suit.
Only he's upgraded the front and back a little.
Like the front is all red now.
There's a very little bit of black.
it's a little bit more like the comics, but sadly,
no daredevil symbol on the front yet.
More on that in a second,
because I think this scene might be a flashback,
so the suit might change multiple times
through the course of the series.
in Bull's Eyes New comic book suit
looks like a combination of Marco Chicos
bullseye suit from 2017 in Bullseye
as costume during the chip Zdarsky
daredevil run is a great way
to reintroduce the characters and it's a great star.
Like this is the first of probably many different
comic book costumes
and it does fit with a more gritty, realistic tone
and vibe of the Daredevil Netflix series.
Only Bummer, though, is that
there is no actual bullseye target on the forehead.
Maybe, maybe at some point that will change.
I'm not expecting them to reference bull's eyes
Adamantium spine from the comics specifically
at the end of the original Daredevil Netflix series,
he was getting his new spine,
but at the time they had a rights issue
where they couldn't use the term adamantium
because Fox still owned the X-Men
and the rights to use the term adamantium.
So nobody in the MCU connected
or even the Netflix series,
anybody outside of Fox could use the term Adamantium.
so the Daredevil Season three showrunner.
So they had to come up with some different story
for the Bullseye character for his spine
and in that version
they were going to say that Doctor Kenji Toyama here,
who was the person in Marvel Comics
who did canonically create the process.
Weapon X used to bind Adamantium to Wolverine skeleton.
so in the comics he was behind all of this adamantium
but because when they were
actually making Daredevil season three,
the Netflix universe was still treated
like it was separate
from the MCU and separate from the Fox X-Men stuff.
They weren't legally allowed to use Adamantium,
so they were going to say that he replaced Bullseye
Spine with a metal alloy called Cognia.
sort of like their discount copier, Right.
Safe version of MCU Adamantium
that had been developed in the Netflix universe
by Oracle, a subsidiary of Iron Fist Company
in those Netflix defender shows.
so Iron Fist was going to be responsible for Bullseye
Eyes new indestructible spine end destructible
metal spine like Wolverine but copyright safe
so they didn't get sued by Fox at the time.
what a difference a couple of years makes during
the original Marvel comics like way back in the classic
Daredevil comics, Doctor Kenji Oyama was from Japan
and developed what he called the adamantium process.
those notes were later
stolen from him by the people running Weapon
X, and they use the process to give Wolverine
his adamantium skeleton.
so this doctor was canonically meant to be the reason
why Wolverine has his adamantium skeleton
now in present day of the Marvel movies,
Kevin Feige is finally introducing Adamantium
in the MCU during Captain America
for using that dead celestial in the Indian Ocean.
Apparently they're just going to say
that adamantium grows naturally on his body,
they're finally going to deal with that dead celestial
everyone's been asking them about
since it debuted at the end of the Eternals movie.
The only real reference that any movies or shows
had made to it since then was during the She-Hulk
episodes of all places, where there was a joke
reference about a giant man being stuck in the ocean.
turns out the reason why no movies taking place
after the Eternals on Earth
in the timeline have dealt with those consequences.
Yet is Marvel, which is saving the storyline
for Captain America for in, once
Adamantium is discovered on team
his body, the entire world wants their hands on it.
Like companies, world governments.
And Val basically wants to get everything
for the United States before
everybody else gets their hands on it.
Originally, I kind of thought they were going to use
the Thunderbolts movie in the Thunderbolts
team to cover that, but it might just happen
during Captain America for basically the take away is
now we have adamantium inside the MCU
also because Marvel got the X-Men rights back,
they can use the concept of Adamantium Weapon
X Wolverine. Now.
see you get to see what's going on in the background
of all the movies.
They're laying the track work in the MCU
for a new version of Weapon X and Wolverine,
but we won't actually see that new MCU Wolverine actor
that they're going to recast until after Hugh
Jackman is done playing his version of Wolverine
in Avengers Secret Wars.
during the fight scene.
It looks like Bullseye
is trying to kill Karen Page at Josie's bar
because in the other scenes they released Matt Foggy.
Karen were having fun at Josie's
until an argument between them broke out
if you saw people in your feed
wondering if Bullseye was going to kill Karen Page
getting worried about that,
that's because Bullseye killed her in the comics.
she's supposed to be in at least three episodes
of the new Daredevil Born Again series.
So I don't expect her to be killed.
both from the looks of Daredevil's fight with them
Bullseye gets at least a couple shots off at Karen
and he tries to stop him.
So maybe Bullseye maybe lands a shot on her
but doesn't kill her, just wounds her very badly.
it kind of seems like
we should be saying our prayers for Foggy Nelson
because he's the one on the ground here.
So maybe he actually takes the bullet for Karen Page.
I'm going to go on a limb here and say that
because they were going to kill Foggy
in the original version of the show,
they probably didn't in this version.
So he's probably
the one that just gets severely wounded.
lot of people seeing red flashing warning lights here.
This will probably seem like a familiar scenario
they kind of did a version of this
during Daredevil Season three where Bullseye was going
after Matt Murdock's friends.
this is really just meant
to be the continuation of that.
you might remember
talk of the original version of the show before
Kevin Feige put the brakes on like fired
a bunch of the showrunner, the writers,
and then hired on a bunch of new people
to come fix the show and make a better version of it,
basically hiring a bunch of the Netflix people
to come back and make the show even better.
Right now, the showrunner from the Punisher
Netflix series is working on this
with some of the Loki writers.
So like a lot of the core stuff,
even the stunt coordinators from the Netflix
series are back in working on this but in the original
canceled version of Daredevil born again
they were supposed to have killed Karen Page and Foggy
Nelson before the present day of the series picks up
which is why I think this scene is actually similar
to what they had originally planned.
But Bullseye really did wind up killing Karen Page
somehow.
and part of the idea
with the aborted version of Daredevil burn again
like we don't need to worry about it now
but in the aborted version he wasn't actually
going to wear the daredevil suit in present day
until like episode four when it picks up.
They were going to give him his own version
of Spider-Man.
No, more like they kind of did a version of that
during Tobey Maguire Spider-Man two,
where he throws the costume away briefly
during the movie, then puts it back on, eventually
Daredevil was going to have a version of that
at the beginning of Daredevil Born Again.
And it was going to be because he couldn't save
or he couldn't protect Foggy Nelson and Karen Page.
Both of them were supposed to have died.
all these scenes of the bullseye
rematch fight scene just makes it feel like
that might have been different
in the original version of the show.
In in this new version, she won't wind up dying
here's where we actually get to the timing
of the actual episode here.
This fight scene, I think the actual fight scene
goes down during episode one
and it might be part of flashbacks to explain
what happens before the snap, just based on Foggy
Nelson's haircut in the new pilot episode
that they were filming a couple of days ago.
if you remember back in the day
after the Game of Thrones season five finale,
we all did the Jon Snow Kit Harington hair
watch for like a year to see if he would cut his hair
and use that as confirmation that he would come back
and film new scenes in Game of Thrones season six.
Like see his hair still the exact same.
Normally he would cut his hair
if he wasn't going to come back.
now we're using Foggy Nelson's facial hair
to do the same thing.
Like he got a big glow up from Daredevil Season
three Last week, they were filming a scene
at their new law firm Murdock, Nelson and Page
paying off the Daredevil Season three, ending with him
creating the new law firm.
So it's been have a bit of a time jump
they're all in their plain clothes having fun
joking with each other heading out on the town
looking like they're heading to Josie's bar
what might be happening at the beginning of episode
one is they might do a flashback to explain
what happened to everyone before the snap,
because we know
that Daredevil is around during the five year time jump
so he didn't get snapped.
We know the kingpin was around, too.
During that five year time jump.
So he also did not get snapped
because that's where that whole echo
fight scene takes place
in where Kingpin pulls her out of police custody.
the other reason why I think they're going
to have scenes that take place before the snap
like before the five year time jump
is because there was a newspaper
on set while they were filming
that brand new version of episode one.
and it features a newspaper
that talks about Kingpin's run for mayor
and whether or not he's going to be able
to fix New York City like it talks about his plan
to fix the city and whether or not
it's going to help him win the mayorship
And I think in the present day of the series, he's
already meant
to have become mayor,
like he'll have won the election already.
I just think episode one is going to have a couple time
jumps to explain what's happened
since the end of Daredevil season
three kind of catch people up to present day
in most of the series will take place in the year 2026
well after the events of Spider-Man
no way home news, A good example.
The present day, the Echo series.
Those episodes were meant to take place
after the events of Spider-Man No Way Home.
So like he gets the idea to run for mayor well,
after Spider-Man, no way home.
then several months later,
eventually winds up winning the mayorship.
so we think the way we get to this daredevil
versus bullseye rematch fight scene
is the moment with bullseye as attack
is meant to take place later in the night
or as connected to the moment of them
leaving their law office.
it looks like Matt and Foggy
get into some kind of argument outside Josie's bar
before the bullseye attack.
Then it seems like bullseye attacks,
Daredevil changes into his suit.
They fight.
Daredevil barely saves Karen Page
they might just use this fight scene
the way it goes down to set more
the circumstance is in the present day of the show
and explain a little bit more about why
Daredevil is the way he is during the five year time
jump, because he almost failed to protect Karen Page
in early theory,
if Foggy gets badly injured trying to save Karen Page
or take the bullet for her, he will be back
later in the series as well as Karen Page.
it, part of what's going on here with the fight scene
two is
this is meant to play into Kingpin's run for mayor
because he runs on an anti vigilante campaign.
Lexi, look at all these terrible vigilantes
causing all this damage, all around New York City.
My plan is to get rid of all of this, But really.
He's just being shady kingpin using it as an excuse
to get rid of Daredevil, Spider-Man,
The Punisher, other heroes
who are also kind of like vigilantes
Kevin Feige keeps talking about how the events
of Daredevil Born Again are going to set up
Spider-Man for The version that they're trying
to make of Spider-Man four is more of a ground level
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man movie, Daredevil
and Kingpin are supposed to be in it
What they could do is they could just have kingpin hire
a lot of the Sinister
Six villains or other Spider-Man villains,
and then they could go after Spider-Man in the movie.
this is a little deeper into the whole Spider-Man
related plot, of all things.
But a lot of people wondering
how they're going to pay off that venom.
Symbiote Post-Credits scene during Spider-Man.
No Way Home.
What they always could do is they could use
Matt Gargan, who's the scorpion
inside the MCU,
and they could give him the symbiote first
if you haven't read The Spider-Man or the Venom Comics,
Matt Gargan did get the symbiote in the comics.
He did become a version of Venom after Eddie Brock.
I still think it's a little early to give Spider-Man
the symbiote during
Spider-Man four, but they eventually do
want to pay that off inside the MCU.
So they could say that for like Spider-Man
five or Spider-Man six or whatever they want to do,
because we still have Avengers Secret
Wars, There's even Avengers five before that.
And it would be cool to see him
get the symbiote during a version of Secret Wars
just so they could do more comic book accurate stuff.
but the other really good news
you may maybe you haven't heard about it
is that Marvel is supposedly reviving other dead shows
the same way that they're bringing back
Daredevil, the X-Men, the animated series.
Other defenders characters are coming back
like Jessica Jones, the Iron Fist character,
not just Danny Rand,
but all versions of Iron Fist from across the timeline,
maybe the cloak and dagger characters, runaways, but
even bigger, I think agents of shield characters.
A lot of people been asking about this for a long time.
Like, when are we going to see agents of Shield
character show up like Chloe Bennet?
Look, this is Ming Na
At the Saturn Awards talking to Kevin Feige,
you can make all the jokes you want about this.
Like, look at her.
Explain to Kevin Feige asking him why Agents of Shield
characters are not in brand new Marvel movies yet.
technically,
they have had Coulson back, but in flashbacks.
So it doesn't really count
the same way we're talking about present day
there are a lot of reasons to complain
about secret invasion, but one of my biggest hopes
that they had actually worked in Chloe Bennet
in some kind of cameo scene,
and she's just been working for Nick Fury
on his saber space station.
maybe like a light reference
on a monitor in the background
doesn't have to be a big cameo,
just like a small reference to the character
even if they don't have big plans
for those agents of SHIELD characters right now
in present day, that's totally fine.
Just referencing the characters would be enough.
Like, yeah, by the way, these characters exist.
They're out there off on missions, busy doing things.
They'll show up eventually.
But they're going to be filming Daredevil Born Again
for a while.
So we'll probably get some more footage
from the actual sets.
The more first looks at the different characters
the other big reminder, we have the Deadpool 3
trailer this weekend, a bunch of other big trailers
Of course, I will do all the videos.
Click here for my brand new Deadpool 3 video and
click here to learn about Marvel bringing back Thanos.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!